One random country has been rising in the odds to win
Eurovision 2024,
and here's which country it is.
So every seven years,
a country that's never won Eurovision wins Eurovision.
In 2,005, it was Greece.
2011, it was Azerbaijan.
In 2017, it was Portugal.
And now in 2024,
Lithuania has a solid chance.
And there's two reasons why. Firstly,
the group has announced that they've submitted an
entry into Lithuania's national selection.
But secondly,
the winner of X Factor Lithuania,
Antoine Wen,
is easily one of
the most talented singers in all of Europe.
And he also expressed his intentions to submit an entry,
too. And this helps to explain why Lithuania
shot up from 23rd in the odds to now sixth.